en ce moment même aux invalides se met
en place la cérémonie en hommage au
caporal-chef masque si mme blasco
comment donc ne pas être par la pensée
autour de tous ces soldats autour de
toutes les familles qui ont perdu un
être cher autour de ses frères d'armes
et de tous ceux qui se sont engagés au
service de la france au service de la
paix ici en france ou à l'extérieur dans
ce contexte madame la ministre des
armées
l'annnonce de la réorganisation de la
force barkan est perçu comme un
désengagement de la france au sahel le
président de la république a dit lui
même que nous n'avions pas vocation à
rester au sahel le mali est en train de
négocier avec des forces russes privées
dit groupe wagner pour assurer dans
l'avenir sa sécurité alors dans ces
conditions et d'aménager deux questions
à vous poser
d'abord si les négociations avec les
russes et le mali aboutissent pas
d'accord qu'a donc qu'allons-nous faire
que la france va-t-elle faire en
réaction à cet accord et puis
parallèlement une autre question qu'avez
vous tirer comme enseignement comme
conclusion de notre départ précipité
d'afghanistan ainsi que celui de nos
alliés des etats-unis d'amérique merci
pour vos réponses la parole est qu à
lavelanet désormais l influence par
leeds avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur d'abord permettez moi de
m'associer à l'hommage que le sénat
vient de rendre à auxerre jean maxime
blasco morts pour la france vous l'avez
rappelé un hommage national lui sera
rendu par la nation toute entière cet
après midi alors vous rappeler que je me
suis rendu au mali récemment et au cours
de ce voyage j'ai pu non seulement
rencontrer nos militaires engagés sur le
terrain et leur dire toute ma
reconnaissance et ma fierté mais j'ai
aussi pu rencontrer le ministre de la
défense du gouvernement de transition
malien dans un contexte où en effet
circulent des rumeurs voire des
informations selon lesquelles
le gouvernement de transition aurait
l'intention de contracter avec une
société de mercenaires
alors j'ai eu l'occasion de dire très
clairement et très directement au
ministre malien ce que la france pensait
de wagner et ce qu'elle pensait des
mercenaires d'une manière générale je
lui ai dit aussi ce que la communauté
internationale en pensait et je le redis
ici devant la représentation nationale
si le mali engage un partenariat avec
des mercenaires
le mali s'isolera
il perdra le soutien de la communauté
internationale qui est pourtant très
engagé au mali
il abandonnera des pans entiers de sa
souveraineté il suffit de regarder ce
qui se passe en république
centrafricaine aujourd'hui est loin de
diversifier ses partenariats
le mali s'enfermera au contraire dans un
tête à tête avec une société de
mercenaires
alors pour nous les choses sont claires
il n'est pas possible de cohabiter avec
des mercenaires et dans ce contexte les
propos du premier ministre du
gouvernement malien tenu à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu samedi der nier sont
inacceptables car accusé la france d'
abandonner le mot le mali au lendemain
de la mort d'un de nos soldats c'est
proprement indécents
monsieur joyandet
merci pour votre réponse claire madame
la mini je m'associe à votre à vos
commentaires sur les déclarations
évidemment du premier ministre du mali
mais je voudrais vraiment insisté sur le
fait que la nation entière est
aujourd'hui en communion avec ses
soldats et nous le savons beaucoup sont
morts pour notre liberté et celle des
générations futures
souvenons nous deux faisons en sorte
madame la ministre qui ne soit pas morte
pour rien c'est un peu le sentiment que
j'ai
regardons ce qui s'est passé en
afghanistan
quel gâchis et donc la bande du sahel
le parallèle n'est pas totalement
judicieux peut-être mais autant plus du
sahel la bande du sahel est vraiment un
endroit stratégique pour le monde pour
l'europe au claf us et pour notre
liberté est vraiment ne partons pas du
sahel nous avons vocation à y rester
c'est de notre avenir c'est notre avenir
qui est en question merci
[Musique]